oui bonsoir et vous le voyez derrière
moi c'est lors de la remise des
médailles dans une ambiance formidable
sur ce magnifique parc équestre
pour vous donner une idée de l'événement
est bien ce championnat de france réuni
1500 club c'est la plus grosse
compétition mondiale d'équitation avec
plus de 7000 participants dix
disciplines et parmi elles vous l'avez
dit l'attelage qu'on a choisi de vous
présenter ce soir
l'attelage est bien c'est une relation
différente entre le cheval et son meneur
rien à voir avec les promenades en
charrette l'attelage de compétition se
veut un sport même si l'ambiance de ces
championnats de france amateur est
plutôt conviviale on est avant tout là
pour s'amuser pour découvrir un peu ce
que c'est la mort
pourquoi vous l'avez choisi d'attelage
parce que poursuit pas les sensations
qui s'adonnent je préfère avant je me
cache mal mais je me suis moins sûr la
page parce que ça me provoque plus de
163 2 1
top départ 11h50 l'épreuve du marathon
se court sur 5600 mètres a effectué en
moins de 23 minutes
les concurrents sont chronométrés à
l'intérieur de cinq obstacles à
combinaison pour le dossard 22 41 37
pour guider son cheval le meneur doit
être habile précis et savoir donner de
la voix
l'esprit du marathon c'est premièrement
d'être agile d'aller vite et de se faire
plaisir sans oublier le look coco
indispensable dans un concours
d'attelage
d'autant plus que l'animal est petit il
est plus petit mais il n'est pas moins
rapide pour autant il
non ils avancent bien bon là aujourd'hui
c'était un peu dur un petit rend donc là
il a eu un peu de mal mais
non mais c'est volontaire c'est
l'attelage une discipline pour tous les
âges adapté à presque toutes les races
de chevaux
serge lecomte bonsoir vous êtes le
patron depuis 11 ans maintenant que
cette fédération française d'équitation
vous êtes aussi le promoteur quelque
part de ce parc équestre à vocation
mondiale toujours plus de chevaux
toujours plus de cavaliers ou est ce que
vous voulez vous arrêter bonjour bonsoir
oui le parc c'est depuis 1994 avec
quelques amis qu'on a créé ce parc j'ai
créé ce parc d'aider les années 94
alors on va s'arrêter ça fait 21 ans
cette année 21e édition ça fait 21 ans
de croissance croissance en termes
d'activité en termes de public
donc les idées fusent quand on est
encouragé à la fois par la participation
du public et par la multitude d
activités qui demandent à s'y dérouler
on a des d'un projet ça serait bien trop
long toute la soirée pour vous les
développer mais en tout cas il ya de la
matière ainsi que vous voulez développer
le concours complet et l'équitation
c'est aujourd'hui le troisième sport
français en nombre de licenciés
il a connu une petite baisse c'est
d'effectifs ces dernières années pour la
première fois comme vous allez faire
pour dépasser le football un jour alors
écoutez on n'a pas l'ambition dépasser
le football il faut être réaliste mais
on a en tout cas l'ambition de rester la
troisième fédération est de continuer à
développer des activités qu'elle put 2
millions de français montent à cheval
donc on se doit de leur donner une âme
de leur donner un destin commun et le
parc équestre fédéral c'est la maison de
famille de tous les cavaliers et toutes
les activités qu'on peut y faire et donc
on peut y développer pour les rassembler
et pour leur donner ce petit tassel
supplémentaires d'appartenir à une
communauté de deux cavaliers et
passionné par la nature est passionné
par le cheval voilà c'est une de nos
missions
or ici c'est le temple de l'équitation
pratiqué en club l'équitation populaire
est ce que le succès de cette base est
ce que c'est la garantie d'avoir plus
tard des médailles d'or aux jeux
olympiques est ce que ça se passe comme
aujourd'hui le parc à 21 ans tous les
grands cavaliers qui participent aux
jeux mondiaux au championnat du monde
aux jeux olympiques etc sont passés par
la mode de vente pratiquement donc non
on se rend compte que c'est une vraie
pépinière et puis je voudrais rajouter
c'est que y'a pas que les manifestations
clubs 1 il y allait y aller les
chantiers les préparations championnats
d'europe il ya les préparations il ya
plein d'événements ya le pôle france
attelage ou toutes les ligues et où vous
venez parler de l'attelage vais tous les
les grands attelage qui est plus dont la
france a une grande tradition viennent
s'entraîner à lamotte beuvron pour
participer à toutes les mêmes concours à
travers le monde
sergio kun vous remercie on nous on se
retrouve demain et on parlera des
finales du saut d'obstacles